the opening of HBO's The Last of Us is
very different than the stars of the
iconic game it's based on but it's all
the better for it here's why the dust
has finally settled on the heartbreaking
and harrowing Premiere episode of The
Last of Us it's only week one and
already we've suffered a tragedy that
has made a dent in our hero Joel it's
had to be done of course Sarah catching
a stray bullet is as vital to Joel's
story arc as Peter Parker losing Uncle
Ben verse what made it special in this
version of the story is how it all
played out not in the actual moments but
in the build up to it Sarah's death in
the show is pretty much as it was in the
original game beats for heart pounding
beats it's as jaw dropping now as it was
back then but the difference in the show
is the route the story took getting
there
and get your uh homework done
fractions
Bob made the live action moment all the
more impactful was the different way
viewers spent time with Sarah versus how
Gamers got to know her and in this
respect the show may have even surpassed
the game let me first meet Sarah in
naughty dog's original game we end up in
her shoes after gifting Joel his
birthday present the game has us
controlling her waking up to emergency
news broadcasts and explosions in the
distance before Joel storms in kills a
neighbor and flees with Tommy onto the
highway to the hell we see in the show
this all happens within the first 20
minutes of the game
okay
kicking things into gear without a
moment's notice was a jarring creative
choice that landed brilliantly in the
game in the show however it's almost the
midpoint of the episode when the world
starts to collapse with more time spent
watching the virus begin to Bubble up
here and there before things explode
into chaos it also does something for
Sarah that the game didn't quite manage
the mechanic behind Sarah's story in the
game that the show doesn't have of
course is the youth Factor as the player
is essential for any gamer to make sure
the character they're controlling
doesn't die which ultimately doesn't
happen after you switch to playing as
Joel carrying Sarah even in this short
timer around her this as to the drama
and makes her demise leave its Mark for
the show though it's a smart move to let
viewers better learn who Sarah really is
it's not just through bedroom or posters
or other environmental details it's her
drifting off at school or heading to see
her elderly neighbor it says kids are
often reluctance about but one that
shows her good nature When Sarah's death
comes on the show it it sits differently
knowing her as a more fleshed out
character the environmental storytelling
is excellent in the original game but it
doesn't compare to the quality time
viewers get in the show with the
character so important to Joel's Arc
that said we could see more of Sarah and
flashbacks or in Joel's dreams which
would only further enhance her character
and by extension the impact of Joel's
story arc talk about a game changer